[Music]
hey on today's show we're going to talk
to the mom of a young toddler with
behavior issues
what can she do to help we're also going
to talk to a big sister who loves her 25
year old brother
what can she do to help him get out of
his funk and we're going to talk to a
mom
of four young kids whose husband treats
her depression like a burden
stay tuned
hey what up i'm john and this is the dr
john delonay show it's a live show where
we walk alongside people
just like you who are trying to figure
out their life their marriages
how to be human beings again how to be
pet owners who aren't idiots
we talk about everything on the show
right anything everything
no matter what's going on in your heart
in your mind or your family there's so
many people
all across the world in that booth
especially
out there today we've got an audience
today we're in this new studio
everybody is struggling with things and
we're all trying to do the best we can
to get our relationships back together
our workplace back together
our families back together all of it so
we're here to talk about everything we
might even talk about people who
complain at restaurants here's the thing
i worked at burger king for four years
joe and linda turner two awesome people
who hired me back in the day when i was
just a kid
their son clay was awesome train me
taught me
people complain at restaurants there's
three kind of people who complain
there's those who complain because
they're just idiots they're trying to
get free things
every group of people has a [ __ ] in it
and there's always that person right
and then there's people who are actually
trying to solve a problem they asked for
this particular meal it didn't come out
like they wanted it they're
pleasant and they're kind and they're
saying hey i asked for this
and i thought i was gonna get this and
then we get it worked out
and then there are those who just love
to complain
and they have such little power in their
lives
they are so unimpressive to the person
they're dating or they're with that they
like to use this moment
a poor waitress or i want to talk to the
manager
right that famous line that just it just
begets control right those people who
just want to complain because it makes
them
feel powerful and they say something
like i don't want anything free or i
don't want you to do anything i just
wanted to
whine and complain so if you're somebody
who's just trying to fix the situation
good for you if you're an idiot thief
and whatever
if you are somebody who complains for
power or complains just because it makes
you feel good
do this find people who love you and
talk to them
because you don't have enough of them in
your life or take an online course that
you can excel at do something that is
going to help you
get ahead in life other than just
whining
so if you've got a problem if you have a
whiner in your life if you've got people
who you love and are just trying to
solve problems you know
the next right crooked wobbly thing to
do please give us a call at
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
and as i figure out this new studio it's
still all shiny and lit up
and bright and shiny it's just shiny
everywhere if you're watching this on
youtube if you're listening to this in
your podcast you have no idea what i'm
talking about
just imagine the shiniest place you've
seen and that's it
and these shiny beautiful people out
here this is so weird good folks
because i've been doing this in a hole
in a studio down below us
for months now and now just seeing you
is super weird
but it's good to see you all beautiful
and even you guys y'all are beautiful as
well
all right so let's go straight to the
phones today um
let's go to christina in calgary
alberta canada christina let's
see what's going on how we doing
christina i'm doing good i'm so
glad to be able to talk to you i'm so
glad that you called how can i help
um i was wondering how can i help my
aggressive preschooler
oh man so tell me what you mean by
aggressive
well um he often hits
or um destroys things mostly
um hitting other people and
it's become more and more of an issue
and i'm sure
a lot of it has to do with the stress of
this year
because this year has been a wreck for
everyone yeah so compounded by covid
one of the things i instantly think of
when i hear about kids
and behavior especially little kids but
really all kids
is behavior is a language right behavior
is just a signal so what is this little
kid trying to say
in whatever environment they are in so
walk me back to the beginning of this
year for you
what's it been like for you you say it's
been awful and bananas what does that
actually mean
well um for the last
well i was pregnant at the beginning of
the year so that was one thing
so i've had a baby since then
and during the time that the pandemic
started
there was a tenant who lived downstairs
who was an exchange student
and he wasn't able to go home when he
was originally planning to and he
thought that my kids were just too loud
and inconsiderate
and he would pound on the floor um
so like from below and it would scare us
and like we had some frightening
episodes that eventually led to panic
attacks
and we stayed at my parents house for a
time um
until things settled down so
you're answering your own question right
partly
but like he's also been aggressive even
since he was a little baby
because as a baby he would even hurt
himself where like we had to hold him
down so he wouldn't like scratch his
face and pull his hair out
yeah and some of that for sometimes
you start trying to look for the cause
of a behavior or the reality of a
behavior
and you start grabbing data points from
all over the place
most of the time a kid who's an infant
who scratches himself or pulls her hair
is just simply trying to figure out
their own body that would be unrelated
to
aggression or some sort of inborn anger
issue
now of course there could be some some
psychological
issues but what you've just laid out to
me
is a lot of stresses
this kid's everything this this young
kid knows how old is he
four three and a half three and a half
okay everything
in this three and a half year old's life
has changed a hundred percent
he had mom's attention now he's got to
share it um he had a safe house
now he's got somebody banging on the
floors making him be quiet
he had a mom who had a life that was
somewhat routine
and now you're living at somebody else's
house everything is dumped over
where's dad in this picture um he's been
around he's been
working or doing school from home
throughout the year
and what what type of dad is he is he
connected dad a plugged in dad or a
everybody shut up i'm trying to do
school dad what kind of dad is he
um most of the time like he's really
good at
spending time with the family when he
doesn't have to work on school
stuff but it's been like more and more
stressful as the year has come
gone on so like he's been a little bit
more
tense as well right and so
children especially young children but
almost all kids really
they absorb that tension
and they process it as though it's their
fault
and then they spend all of their life
trying to mitigate it
and for a kid that tension is a broken
relationship with its k
with their caregivers which is you and
your husband a three and a half year old
cannot process
a new baby has just moved in a three and
a half year old cannot process
stressed out parents a three and a half
year old especially can't process
mom and dad are present they're in the
house
physically but they are not emotionally
or mentally present because they're
having to work from home or do school
from home
and so everything in your kid's life has
gone up in smoke if you will so
here's a couple so backing out to my
original question
what's your kid trying to say your kid
is trying to tell you that they're not
safe
that they are disconnected that there
are no
boundaries things are free-flowing and i
don't know where i'm gonna live i don't
know who's gonna be banging on our
floors et cetera
so here's here's a couple of things i
can give you to
help you walk through it number one kids
are desperate
desperate for sleep and nutrition
they are desperate for connection and
they are desperate for boundaries
okay so sleep and and
nutrition tired exhausted over-sugared
kids
um kids with allergies or discomfort
from food that just feel
uncomfortable all the time kids who just
are plugged into electronics all the
time and so they don't
when they are asleep they're not
actually going into their full rem cycle
sleep
um kids who are not running around
outside and are locked into an apartment
and i know that's so hard during
pandemic depending on what what city you
live in
and what jurisdiction you live in
because some are just shut down you
can't leave your apartment at all ever
and that's wreaking havoc on little kids
the second thing is they're desperate
for connection
and when i mean connection i mean the
whole world stops
you get down an eye level you look kids
in the eye you touch them a lot and
you've probably heard me say that over
and over whether it's
touching their their hands or their feet
or their face
having a nighttime ritual that includes
lots and lots of
safe heavy touch on a on a child
whether that's playing getting down on
their level and playing
laying on your stomach and playing legos
or blocks with a three and a half year
old that's reading
age-appropriate books right
if there's no abuse and there's no hurt
then connection is
a great gift if there is abuse if there
is fear in a kid then that
that connection can be traumatic too so
that's a whole other situation i don't
hear that here
and then the next the last thing here is
boundaries
if a three and a half year old feels
like they are running your house
and what i mean by that is if they can
scream and not eat something
if they can kick and scream and you'll
just shove a tv in front of them or an
ipad in front of them
then they are in essence running the
house and
that destroys a kid they aren't designed
to carry that sort of weight
and they are desperate for mom and dad
to put up boundaries
put up um barriers that they will lean
and press to make sure they'll hold
but they're desperate for them because
then it makes them feel safe it's like
swaddling i remember the first time i
swaddled my son i thought i was
i was gonna kill him like it was the
worst nightmare for me that someone
would tie my arms in like that
until a doctor buddy of mine explained
no that's when they feel safe they don't
feel safe with these wild appendages
flying around scratching them and
pulling their hair out because they
don't know how they work
they feel safe when they're bound up and
so when you look
back over the the course of this year i
want you to be graceful to yourself as a
mom because it's been chaos
i want you to be graceful to yourself as
a brand new mom because you've got a um
what like a nine month old in your house
and now a three and a half year old
but i want you to do some things that
are going to draw some boundaries here's
some boundaries
you cannot hit in this home you cannot
scream in this home
that's not a that's not a tool that
works for you
i am going to intentionally put down
the little one or give the little one to
dad and i'm going to spend some very
direct connective time with you
on a regular basis at a regular time if
possible
and that way we can build in time
boundaries with our kids we can build in
attention connection boundaries with our
kid i'm gonna make
super sure that the moment he wakes up
i'm gonna give him
skin to skin contact direct skin to skin
contact i'm going to make sure that
before lunch
after nap and right before bed there is
some direct skin to skin contact
and i also i haven't experienced this
but i've just heard over and over for
moms when you are in this season when
you're still nursing you've still got a
a young one at home your body doesn't
feel like yours and the last thing you
want to do is touch
another kid last thing you want to do is
touch your spouse you just don't touch
anybody
but i'll tell you those investments in
touch those investments in eye contact
will
pay off in a decrease screaming a
decrease
biting and kicking and a decreased
language of will somebody please
freaking look at me
will somebody please acknowledge me and
that's all your three and a half year
old is doing with his little languages
he has
if things like attention if things like
limited screen time if things like
bedtime routines where you're getting a
lot of sleep
a lot of sleep for a young kid like that
probably 10 to 12 hours for a young kid
like that
a lot of nutrition no sugar
very limited stuff out of a box give a
kid as healthiest
food as y'all can afford if those things
don't work
then i'm going to recommend you go see a
psychologist but i want you to spend 30
days
double down on the connection double
down on boundaries time boundaries
double down on space double down on
consistency
and here's the hard thing for moms and
dads listening to this
this means that you all are going to
have to be highly highly intentional
you have to be highly intentional about
when you wake up and how much sleep you
get
about meal plep and meal meal prep and
meal planning
you're gonna have to be intentional
about um budgets you're gonna have to be
intentional about who does just shopping
you have to be intentional all those
things that couples just let roll
especially when you've got a newborn in
the house
you're gonna have to be overly
intentional about it
and then you're gonna have to really
communicate with your husband sounds
like he's an awesome guy i feel like
he's a great dude who's plugged in and
trying to help the best he can while
doing
two or three other things here's the
other thing
this is a season and it will pass this
season is hard this season sucks i've
seen his wing
season's wing everybody and if you're in
an apartment with an angry tenant
surrounding you that does not understand
the beauty of little kids
and who's a jerk who's banging on the
ceiling like an idiot
and if you've got two little babies in
that house it's just hard it just
is and so um try those things with your
little one call me back if they don't
work call me back if they do work that
would be great to know
and appreciate your call all right let's
go out to erica in grand
rapids michigan erica what's happening
how are we doing
good how are you destiny thanks for
taking my call thank you so much for
calling what's going on
cool um i'm calling to get some advice
on how to interact with my
25 year old brother who's just becoming
a very angry
person particularly in the
what he wants to do with his life
career-wise
he has a degree in business
administration and
graduated about 18 months ago and since
then he's had four different jobs
one of them he lost because he was the
new kid on the block for
kovid so that was kind of you know out
of his control but
he comes to me you know asking for
advice and just gets very angry when i
either try to give him some advice or
guidance or suggestions
um sometimes it's very um very
productive and then other times it's i
get hung up on saying well you just
don't know how it is
kind of thing based on what he wants to
do
it's difficult because i i see him
starting to turn into an angry person
um and kind of starting to distance
himself from
myself and my my parents so where does
this
where does your brother get this
sort of life from is he modeling that
uh yeah unfortunately i do start to see
some
transfer over my dad has kind of been
in and out of work for the last five
years
and it's i i don't tend to hear what the
reasoning why
he is no longer employed there but it's
always uh there's other other people
caused the
determination of his employment kind of
thing and
so that's kind of put a strain on my mom
to handle all the finances on her own
um and especially with um
you know all the things that are going
on and whatnot my dad just doesn't
really seem to have uh much interest
outside of
youtube and uh and whatnot so
um that's where all the good conspiracy
theories are erica
yeah well that and you know and this
thing and that thing
yeah if you would quit working your
regular job and paying attention to your
regular family you could see
all the cool things on youtube including
this
this mildly entertaining show right well
yes you know of the 33 people that do
watch it i
think those 33 get some good advice out
of that that's right so
so does your brother have friends does
he have people in his life that are will
just tell me he's being an idiot or no
um
yes i would say so he switched colleges
midway through um and so he has
more friends at the first college that
he started out with
and he tries he seems to gravitate more
towards them but they
kind of live in a different area than
where he lives
he is actually moving out of my parents
house
in january finally kind of thing
more so it was he was trying to save
money
because it was expensive and then being
out of a job
living you know at home was just a
little bit easier but
um it's it's one of those i'm trying not
to be a second mom
to him because we're seven years apart
and kind of always been
the joke that he has two moms kind of
thing but you know
my dad and his brother don't have a good
relationship with each other
but i would like to keep that with my
brother but i also don't want to get
hung up on
or people i just don't know what i'm
talking about kind of thing whereas
you know if you're at a job for four
months and you want to leave within two
weeks of starting because you didn't get
adequate
training and then you know the
suggestion is we'll speak up
well no i can't do that and x y or z
ring run kind of thing
so here's i'll give you some good news
and then some bad news okay and i'll go
with start with the bad news the bad
news is
you can do nothing yep there's nothing
you can do here to
help your brother do anything
differently
yeah especially if he's not coming to
you
humbly and saying i need help with a
plan
and dude i'm the worst there's been
seasons of my life when i've been the
worst brother i've got an older sister a
younger brother
where i've called them unsolicited just
giving them all kinds of shenanigans
like well you know what you should be
doing and it's insulting and it's
demeaning
it and here's the thing i think i was
right i probably still think i was right
but it wasn't helpful right and so
talk backing out and talking about your
brother here's what your brother is he's
25 he said
yeah your brother's terrified yeah
and he's terrified of two different two
different tracks number one
those feelings he has that people at
work don't like him that everyone around
him is out to get him
those feelings aren't truthful they're
not right but they feel real
and that's scary and yeah depending on
how your dad
and your mom raised him guys have
very limited skills in responding to
fear and usually it's to puff your chest
out and just start swinging
or it's to numb it out and you can numb
out with alcohol with youtube with
more work or with another job and
another job or another girlfriend or
another girlfriend another drink
but you're just going to spend your life
numbing and running right yeah the
second thing
definitely been he's definitely been the
person his whole life that school was
hard for him teachers were out to get
him
right um and when throw my hands up any
time that it got
gets difficult and have somebody else
figure it out there you go
aka mom and dad and that leads me to
number two which is he is terrified of
becoming his dad
and it's happening before his his very
eyes it's like watching somebody whose
dad is bald and it's that first time you
swipe your comb through
and you just see all that hair come out
and you're like oh no right it just it
happens in slow motion to your life
and oh so here's the thing you have a
scared
to death 25 year old little brother that
you can't help
yeah all you can do for him is to love
him
and to say i you can call me anytime
here's my recommendation to you and it's
gonna be trite and not
super helpful um it will be when he
calls you to ask your
opinion on things i would stop him
before he gets rolling which
i'm guaranteeing he's a roller he'll
talk and just talk and talk and talk and
talk and talk and talk and talk
and you'll start to try to get in he'll
just take a breath and keep going
is i'm right am i right on that oh yeah
okay so i would start him i'll stop him
before he gets going and ask him
do you want my um advice or you just
need somebody to listen to because i'd
love to listen to you
and let him choose because then if you
start to pipe up with
here's what i think you need to do you
can always fall back on hey you asked me
for this
yeah otherwise just be a safe quiet
place for him to talk
and vent and talk and vent and then you
need to live your life above reproach
and what i mean by that is you will be a
shining light you'll be the example for
him that he doesn't have
right and you may reach out to him with
with good things that are happening in
your life you may reach out with him
just to check on him you may write him
letters that tell him that he's loved
and he's a good guy
and that um when he when he does
something good we do that with kids
right catch him being good
but write him a actual physical letter
that he can hold in his hands that's
tactile that he can see it
and he's a millennial he won't even know
what's happening he'll be like what's
this
mail thing you speak of right but send
him a letter he can open it and see it
and touch it and feel it
and he's going to have to learn
a really hard and uncomfortable lesson
and that is work sucks
and the real world's hard and nobody
gives you anything
and you've got to fill you know right
fill in the blank all those things sure
and that does lead me to this um it's
almost
i don't want to be all ranty today here
in this new studio it's all shiny
i don't want to get spittle everywhere
but
there's a whole generation of young
person who's been told this one
like fascinating line which is follow
your passions
almost like it's you say it you say i'm
breathy follow your passions right like
the deeper
like a like a mega church preacher who
are just talking in regular voices and
then they're like
so one day i was walking along the road
and then i met god they have to only say
it in a breathy breathy way right
it's the same way follow your passions
and
for most kids there's no backup to that
there's no information that goes along
with that and so what passion becomes is
a marker for feelings
follow your feelings do the thing that
feels most comfortable to you
and if there's any sort of resistance if
things are hard
i want to be an author well just write a
book and then the first person reads it
like hey this book kind of sucks that's
not good
or you've got to pay attention in
english class so you can learn how
an actual sentence functions right or
fill in the blank i want to be a poet i
want to be a runner i want to be a
whatever follow your passions that means
follow your feelings
and then when things get hard then i
feel sad i don't want to feel sad so i
just abandon it and quit
i go somewhere else and that's
just absolutely wreaked havoc on a whole
generation of human being
and really it starts with my generation
they were telling us follow your dreams
follow your passions you can be anything
here's the thing about follow your
passions
you become passionate about the things
you're good at
and you become good at the things that
you practice
the things that you do over and over and
over and over again
and if you're like 99.9 of the world
there's always that one kid that just
sits in front of youtube learns how to
play the guitar
and he comes out nine months later and
he's just savant every generation has
that kid good for you i'm not talking
about them
most of you are not steve jobs right or
you wouldn't be listening to this
podcast
the rest of us practice the things that
we were made to do
my parents made me be really good at
mowing the yard my dad
was really hard on me about mowing the
yard because he said it communicated a
couple of things it communicated how i
cared about a customer it communicated a
sense of excellence that was inborn
regardless how much i was making
it was a sense of pride for the
homeowner all these things came through
right
joe and linda there at burger king treat
the customer that comes in here
with respect you don't know where
they're coming from we happen to be on a
route to a hospital people would stop
there to get food to go visit their
loved ones at a hospital
just laughing and bringing joy into that
day brighten people up right
but we were made to do it if you treated
a customer with disrespect they called
you in the back and they
said you're not going to work here if
you're like that right and so
you're passionate about things you're
good at you're good at things your
practice your practice the things you're
made to do
and when you're made to do things it's
hard and you don't like it and it's not
fun and there's some times that you are
practicing things and you have good days
of practice and bad days of practice
right
there are sometimes you are things doing
things that you're really good at and
then you don't do them good that day
you don't do them good that month you
have a low season you work really hard
on your next big book
and it tanks right steven spielberg has
some movies that didn't do well
that's part of it and
being told to do things that are hard
being made to do things that are hard is
not mean to your children it's not mean
to your students it's not mean to
teenagers
it gives them a sense of fortitude
and grit that comes from the inside out
the fancy word for that is resilience
not feelings feelings are true you got
to sit down and
i mean not true feelings are real you
got to sit down and acknowledge them but
they lie to you
and this sounds like a young man that
has been told
his entire life yeah you know what
i know you feel that that teacher is
being mean to you you're right let's go
get her
i know you feel like that job's hard you
should quit they should treat you better
and you feel your feeling feel your way
through 100 different jobs
through frustration through broken
relationships
no no work to stand upon
and when you don't have any work to
stand upon you don't have relationships
to stand upon you are
nothing we are made as relationships we
are made to work period that's just the
way that is
and so for everybody out there who is
doubling down on my what's my passion
what's my passion
go back to the things you were made to
do go back to the things that you're
going to practice
over and over and over and over these
poor james and kelly
zach these poor folks you should see the
hours of tape
that we have on they called it radio
school
these guys back it was a beating it
still is a beating for them i'm still
learning how to do this right
but we had to practice and practice and
then james would say we're going to be
here at this time you got to be here at
this time
and it would be uncomfortable not good
they made me do it and you get better
and better and now i'm starting to love
it
now i'm starting to like it it's
starting to be fun i'm starting to be
quote unquote passionate about it right
so erica to answer your original
question there's nothing you can do man
you can love your brother be connected
to your brother i'd stop on the advice
unless he explicitly asks
and you can feel free to tell them this
if i tell you this i'm going to hold you
accountable to it okay
and he may not want to do that he may
say
whatever 25 year olds with five jobs in
four months say
but man just gets me frustrated dude all
right i'm gonna quit talking on it let's
go to katie
in waco texas katie what is up
in tejas oh
um cold for texas
it's cold yes
wow i just talked to someone from canada
and they didn't even start the call that
way
all right so how are we doing what can i
do to help uh
we're doing doing doing doing all right
um
uh we've been having
issues uh i have i we
in marriage um
with my husband late as of late has
treated
you know depression issues that i have
occasionally as an issue of frustration
and seems to be quite the burden on him
and i don't really know how to handle it
and go about it when that's kind of just
feeds into the depression
are you depressed
yeah um yes sir
uh i have an issue and
this is not something brand new to me or
even in
our relationship it
comes and goes and sometimes we have
harder times
sometimes i have better times sure you
know how long have you been married um
we have been officially married
for just over a year okay we
we've lived together for almost three
years i'm 27
he is 30. okay so i don't i want to talk
just about you for a little bit okay
um how long have you struggled how long
have you
been depressing how long have you been
struggling with depression
i i mean
off and on throughout pretty much my
life
through seasons or issues or okay
kind of whatever's going on um i mean
you want to get way way back i was in
sixth grade complaining of stomach ache
so frequently my mom took me to the
doctor and the doctor told her to take
me to therapy
okay so for for most people
most of the time depression
anxiety that's your body's way of trying
to protect it
and it doesn't always feel like it's
helpful but your body is doing the best
it can to protect you
so what what is your
body still trying to protect you from
what in your past does it not want to
deal with what relationships
are broken it sounds like from since
when you were a kid
well yeah you know i grew up in one of
those homes
uh the you know my parents divorced when
i was young
my dad was an alcoholic my mom would
rarely would have touched a drink so but
you grew up in a disconnected house with
disconnected folks and they doesn't mean
they didn't love you that didn't mean
they didn't try but
um you were launched out
right and your body's been doing the
best it can to protect you for a long
long time
right yes sir and a lot of that
protection
i'm just going to guess here has
something to do with some sort of
withdrawing
whether it's somatic pains which is nerd
speak for your stomach hurts your foot
hurts your head hurts your back hurts
what or whether that is
disconnecting from relationships from
pulling back right from
withdrawing am i on the right right
right track here yeah
yeah so um
a little context here we do have um
there are four little boys in our house
what ages are they so um
our new one is uh
four almost four months old and i've got
a
four five and seven four
five in seven in four months
yes how many of those are biologically
yours
they're all mine the new one
is biologically hit the other three are
not his but
no but he's so graciously and i mean he
is a good
man he is a very good man i am not going
to say he's like
a terribly horrible person by any means
so i'm going to reframe your husband for
you for a minute okay and i may be way
off
and people accuse me of being too
optimistic sometimes
but that guy loves you
do you agree with that yeah does he love
you a lot
i'd like to think so okay no don't don't
do that does he love you a lot
yeah okay i think he does he took on
three of your kids
he has dated you for several years he
married you he loves you
and there is nothing more painful
in the world than watching somebody you
love
hurt and when you have
a depressive episode when your body for
whatever is coming on in your
environment whether it's you've got a
four month old for god's sakes
or four kids seven in age under in the
middle of a pandemic
in the middle of a wacky city that's
growing but not growing and kind of
growing there in waco
in the middle of a state that doesn't
know what what
what day it is sometimes right all of
those things
happening at the same time and then some
and then some right and historical
trauma that your body is still wrestling
with
and your husband looks at the woman he
loves more than anybody else in the
world
and sees her hurting and it's hard to
watch
and some guys and by some i mean almost
all of us
myself included don't always have the
right tools to know what to do
when i can't run out and just strangle
it or i can't run out and write a mean
letter to it
to solve it right i can't go out and
have a stern conversation with her or
whatever we were trained to do
and so sometimes that frustration that
feels like a burden
is simply a powerlessness that your
husband has over
the the pain the woman he loves is
feeling
yeah right and so i'm gonna
put him to the side i'm gonna assume
he's a good guy trying to figure out
what he can
do how he can help and yeah he's
frustrated and yeah he's got xyz and
he's not going to say the right things
all those things right of course
the question i want to ask you is do you
want to be
done with depression
well yeah who doesn't well
so but it comes with a cost
and that's why i'm asking and it may not
be a conversation that you can complete
on this call because it's going to be a
more long-term thing
but if you want to be done at some point
you have to go back to that six-year-old
little girl
whose dad didn't show up because he was
drunk again
whose mom wouldn't touch a drink she did
all the right things but
was trying to protect you and if you
have any siblings from
an alcoholic dad a six-year-old who's
still trying to figure out what she did
to make her parents split up
and you're going to have to let that
little girl go play
you're going to have to let her off the
hook because she's still trying to
protect you now
and as you have four kids
three by somebody else or more than one
other person
you are starting to the cycle is
starting to repeat itself
and then instep's this guy that loves
you
and that's when i ask you this that's
the stage i'm setting to ask you this
question do you want to be done with it
because if you want to be done with it
it's going to take
some hard work on your part and it means
you're going to have to connect with
people in a way that you probably don't
have the skills to connect
and you're going to have to say the same
as you like i had i want to learn
spanish
i want to learn how to knit i'm going to
learn how to connect with other people
because i did not get that skill growing
up
and i'm not going to do that to my four
kids
yeah i do not need better
no no they don't need better they need
you
yeah they need their mama because i know
you love those kids too don't you
yes sir a lot very very much
all right so here i want you to paint me
a picture
real quick what is a life free of
depression what does that look like for
you
i understand the question
totally what is it i mean what does it
look like
peace yeah there you go i guess yeah
i'll paint you some pictures okay i'll
put some things out there
you got four knuckle-headed little boys
and your
body feels good enough that you can roll
around on the floor of them and have a
big dog pile wrestling match every
afternoon
and you cannot react loudly you cannot
react through yelling or screaming or
withdrawing when one of them acts like
a five-year-old or a seven-year-old or a
four-year-old
and that you and your husband can have a
budget meeting together you can have a
um hey we're not having enough sex
conversation together and you can have
it in a way that's not a fight but just
more of a hey
i need you to lean in on this area more
and i need to lean on that area more
or hey you've been working a lot of
hours i'd love just to have some time
with you
i'm sleepy and i'm just gonna go to
sleep with no meds
right i'm gonna take time to read a book
this i'm gonna do something that's not a
netflix special i'm gonna go for a walk
out there by the river there in waco
that's what i'm talking about not that
you're not gonna have sad days and
frustrated days and angry days
but the word you gave me is peace and
here's the thing if you
learn how to not be depressed what you
can do
you're not gonna be healed you're gonna
be empty you're going to have to
learn some new skills and if you go into
this that way
if you lean into learning new skills
giving yourself permission to fall down
and be graceful let your husband know
tell him to give me a call too okay but
i want you to hear me say this
katie those four little boys deserve
this
that knuckleheaded husband of yours
deserves this and more than anybody
you deserve to let that little girl go
play and you deserve
peace
thank you do you believe me yes
okay so here's the deal i'm holding you
accountable to
this in 30 days i'm going to email you
back
i'm going to email you back and i'm
going to find out if you've gone to
see a counselor there in waco i'm going
to find out if
you and your husband have sat down and
had a conversation about
what does it look what does healing look
like what are some things he can do
not to give you advice not to get
frustrated but to start helping
in the in the house helping around the
house what are some
little wins what are some things you can
start doing i'm going to commit to
taking a walk
every day i'm going to take my kids out
for the walk we're just going to go walk
around the neighborhood i'm going to
commit because i'm going to be a steward
of my body
and be a steward of my mind i'm going to
be a steward of fill in the blank
i'm going to go back and watch all these
videos on youtube of
this show i'm going to really go down
the rabbit hole i'm going to
read or get audio books i'm going to do
the things i'm going to begin to learn
some of this stuff
and then the hard stuff i'm going to
start practicing it so i'm going to
email i'm going to put a note on my
calendar kitty i'm going to email you
in a month i'm going to check in on you
see how you're doing
i want you to be honest with me but i
believe in you and i believe that this
is the season that that cycle is going
to get broken
because you're going to choose i don't
want to be depressed anymore i don't
want to live in that life
i want to be peaceful
i want to be somebody of peace i'm so
glad that you call kitty
and tell that husband look at your
husband in the eye and say hey
i know you're frustrated but i talked to
a guy on the radio he told me it's just
because you love me
and i'm hurting and you don't know what
to do
and so then give him a big hug and then
just give him a big smooch
just tell him i love you that's not
gonna help a lot but that'll be fun for
me all right as we wrap up the show here
oh man this actually is i went to this
show
i went to watch these guys open up for
john mayer and
i love john mayer i think he's
extraordinary he's a great songwriter
he's hilarious he's an ex like
the best guitarist of my generation but
this band came out
and they made art on a stage in a way
that i don't think i've ever seen
anybody do it was extraordinary
but this song kind of went quiet on
their hit
record their 1993 record and it's one of
my favorite songs ever
and they came out and opened the show to
this and that stuck in my head one of
those live performances just stays with
you forever
so after 1993 august and everything out
after
record the counting crows
wrote rang king and adam sings
when i think of heaven deliver me in a
black winged bird
i think of flying down in your sea of
pins and feathers
and all the instruments of faith and sex
and god in the belly of a black winged
bird
don't try to feed me because i've been
here before and i deserve a little more
and i belong in the service of the queen
and i belong
anywhere but in between and she's been
crying and i've been thinking
and i'm the rain king i said mama mama
mama why am i so alone cause i can't go
outside i'm scared
i might not make it home well i'm alive
i'm alive but i'm sinking in and if
there's
anyone at home at your place darling why
don't you invite me in
don't try to feed me because i've been
here before and i deserve a little more
and i belong in the service of the queen
and i am the rain king
this has been the dr john dolone show
you